[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sean lucas salut les terriens bienvenue
dans votre top 10 h du soir bonsoir
cinq terrains de choix avec nous ce soir
à mme hidalgo
anne hidalgo bonsoir vous êtes candidate
ps à la mairie de paris vous êtes ici ce
soir pour nous parler de votre politique
du logement alors vous allez construire
des cartons au bord du canal saint
martin
pas de carton noms des vrais logements
clara morgane
[Applaudissements]
tamada bon soir alors vous êtes ici ce
soir est pour répondre à la question que
personne ne vous a jamais posée est-ce
que vous avez dû coucher pour réussir
et l'écouté oui oui j'ai couché avec mon
petit ami dévoile avec greg chanteur
division et l'inconnu
pensons à connais pas je suis très
heureux de recevoir le trio le plus
célèbre de france juste après françois
hollande valérie trierweiler
en p3 après le zapping gaspard proust
nous accueillerons notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures ce soir alexis vastine
le boxer en maudit des jeux olympiques
dont les larmes sur le ring avait ému
toute la france il repart au combat nous
sommes ensemble jusqu à 20h25 en
compagnie des violons des consuls
[Musique]
les inconnus romont soir donc les
inconnus se reforme après 13 ans de
séparation c'est bon c'est réglé les
histoires avec yoko ono ça va il ya plus
de problème ouvrez vous aviez peur que
les gens vous reconnaissent plus parce
que ne pas reconnaître les inconnus
c'est assez paradoxal
non tiens qu'est les réseaux sociaux sur
internet sedar et un carton donc il ya
une télé nostalgie aujourd'hui toute
façon non à y ait un petit peu ça vous
en profiter thierry et
jamais les gens ont dit que coluche se
reforme
c'est incroyable d euros alors en fait
vous êtes retrouvés tous les trois
ensemble sur scène en février 2011 lors
de la dernière représentation de la
pièce de le pascal avec mathilda may
plus si affinités et l'a dit vous avez
senti qu'il se passait quelque chose le
public était content c'est vrai que la
ferveur du public à ce moment là le fait
de nous retrouver à 3 ça nous a un petit
peu ça a été vraiment le truc qui nous a
poussés quoi asie un bon ben on va
retarder d'ailleurs au départ on devait
retravailler un spectacle on s'est dit
d'abord un film puis le spectacle on
verra
lui avoir lieu le spectacle non non j'ai
un deal à faire
jamais la france entière donc 67
millions de personnes vont voir le film
peut-être qu'on fera spec d'accord voilà
voilà
avec un peu moins de gens c'est possible
aussi bouzid il fallait attendre d'avoir
envie ne provoque pas à l'envi faut
attendre le bon moment faut que sois là
au bon moment ce fut long mais pas une
question d'argent c'est une question de
beaucoup d'argent
non au contraire la banque curieusement
d'ailleurs à votre question le
présupposé c'est qu'en fait on a eu
quand même un peu de difficulté à monter
le film un vrai mais on a trouvé un très
bon producteur qui s'appelle phil baudot
situe dans les inconnus 7,4 de liens et
donc on l'a monté en participation enfin
la contrepartie intéressante c'est qu'on
a plus de liberté oui donc j'ai payé sur
les ondes très bien ça donc s'ils
viennent au londres est très content
c'est un peu con de faire ce film qui va
être un blockbuster au moment où les
revenus de plus d'un million d'euros
sont taxés à 75 points c'est ce que
j'avais dit à bernard k faisons le
sarkozy
alors le film qui vous réunit s'appelle
les trois frères le retour au départ ça
devait s'appeler les trois frères amis
pour la vie mais ça porte malheur
ça
vole c'est mieux quand même je sais pas
mais des contacts et clara pour une
version les trois frères en même temps
mais
alors été arrêté à
paraître
alors pour des raisons d'égalité de
temps de parole
vous allez me faire le pitch lors du
film là après l'eau c'est un peu le
salut non mais c'est le retour c'est en
fait le retour de louis des trois frères
ben oui qui se retrouvent donc ensemble
quinze ans plus tard
réunis autour des cendres de la mer qui
reviennent des états unis et à ce moment
là que les emmerdes commencent quoi eh
ben c'est parfait on va regarder les
garçons
6 en fait surtout les transcende non
oui
[Musique]
hériter ne signifie pas seulement
percevoir nos sia quitter selon qui des
crédits de tête mais faut payer
nous je savais qu'il fallait pas qu'on
soit peut-être penser un petit peu
enterrés calumet de la paix ta gueule
c'est un bête de conflans pourquoi
serait-ce là dessus you know problème à
cela nos fans on attend de la famille on
t'a dit la capture il faut un sms de
confirmation
tila cristal l'avant fin des quelque
chose cet avis non mais sarah c'est
vachement dangereuse et l'aspartame qui
n'ont pas trop ça fait pas mention
ça c'est bien maintenant au pays mais
c'est ça ou est-ce que tu as mis ce
sachet de mdma
bien le faire le barbare mais bon pour
l'instant c'est un bonsaï
[Musique]
non il est nommé longchamp castagnetta
ni c'est pas ça j'ai dit on ce programme
un surprenant
salle aux
policiers dans un cinéma êtes chez vous
alors didier vous êtes cuit dans le film
toujours le même quinze ans plus tard la
mito je crois que je suis prof de philo
et gelant des godemichés voilà sur un
parking sera pas requis par internet ça
c'est un côté moderne vont faire le mec
est quand même deux mais bon au large de
la réalité
pas trop bernard vous êtes qui dans le
film paraît très proche des réalités je
crains médias raté
qui voit la mer façon heure de gloire il
a quand même fait une pub mais c'est son
fardeau il a fait une pub avec un chien
tout le monde veut qu'il a voilà est en
fait il n'a pas envie il fait le casse
du plateau maintenant et voilà donc qui
supporte mal ça parce qu'ils estiment
qu'ils méritent mieux il d'ailleurs il a
un one man show qui fait rire que lui
pascal alors vous c'est énorme alors moi
celle du hainaut brabant
je suis très très très loin de la
réalité en fait je vis je vis chez une
cougar pour la satisfaire j'utilise du
bois bandé qu'un peu de viagra voilà des
gentils voilà en fait grâce à elle j'ai
le gîte et le couvert non pas le gîte et
le couvert
il ya des scènes qui m'ont fait marrer
ya la vieille ans la cheminée j'ai
trouvé ça très très drôle et puis le
quart loge de mimie mathy faire
calmement il en le carrelage de
l'initiative vous imaginez comment il se
tape la tête chaque fois qu'ils bougent
pas y perdre c'est drôle is in et alors
il ya cette fille donc s'appelle sofia
lesaffre la clé petite bête qui est
formidable avec le 16 ans un côté un
gros bébé qui parle de drogue
et d'une violence ouais les majorités du
matin c'est une femme enfant c'est un
bien en voyant le film votre ancien
impresario paul lederman avait les
larmes aux yeux enfin surtout parce
qu'il vous a plu ce contrat ma vie
bon dans tous les câbles à messieurs
après led zeppelin et police les
inconnus se reforme et c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle
clara morgane dreux bonsoir
contrairement aux inconnus vous n'êtes
pas ici pour nous annoncer votre retour
au cinéma
hélas
depuis plusieurs années vous avez arrêté
votre carrière dans le x 12 ans voilà
pour devenir chanteuse animatrice télé
femme d'affaires d'habitude c'est
l'inversé
ouais j'ai voulu essayer les choses
jeunes voilà en tous les cas aujourd'hui
il est devenu une fille sage
si on peut dire le garage c'est du
sérieux journée
voilà marie laure votre carrière dans le
x a été assez courte 1 en 500 cc rien
oui le temps de l'expérience et le temps
de me trouver est ce que c'est vrai
j'avais une éducation un petit peu
rigoriste j'avais beaucoup d'en vider
d'envié un peu qui peuvent paraître
extrême parfois mais j'en avais besoin
d'eux et pas en adoré fait beau film
avec le même homme oui votre homme greg
grudge avait rencontré l'âge de 16 ans
ouais qu avec greg et avec une scène
avec ken scott j'attends des doigts
parce que je savais c'est là tu vas voir
si vous étiez honnête non mais moi j'ai
deux scènes avec ian scott non c'est une
tendance que tu vois les candidats tu
exactement un an j'étais fidèle oui à
mon petit ami de l'époque et ensuite on
s'est séparés j'ai fait une dernière
scène avant de partir comme un coup
d'éclat voilà alors vous avez une
carrière courte vous êtes quand même
pour les français la star du x et oui
c'est incompréhensible mais non si c'est
parce que je pense que j'ai présenté le
journal du hard pendant sept ans donc
voilà j'ai cette image de fille qui
assume en tout cas les jadot vous adore
il vous kiffe grave
[Musique]
k
car à ce jeu suit morgane de toi ça sur
internet ceux des millions de vu ça
alors résultats donc aujourd'hui vous
êtes sages vous vendez votre image vous
dites je suis un produit marketing entre
autres c'est vrai que je fais de la
photo de la lingerie et j'ai une boîte
de production je fais de la musique j'ai
beaucoup de chance et bien pub les
cornichons tu veux vous faire découvrir
quelque chose de vraiment excitant un
truc tout nouveau tu va plaire aux
amateurs je vais vous montrer
[Musique]
d'abord j'adore imaginer ce qui va se
passer juste après la mise en bouche ce
petit moment d'attentes juste avant
cette explosion du cal vous allez voir
on va essayer tout de suite mois
avant qu'on commence il faut savoir que
lé général est très importante mais que
mes critères de sélection principaux
sont le toucher et le goût
ils sont aussi différents mais ce que je
préfère par dessus tout c'est leur
taille
j'adore les petits
et heureusement
je m'en remettrai parce que c'est entre
la pub et le sketch et c'était
l'occasion de produire ma première pub
que j'ai coréalisé aussi donc le fc
content de ce truc là c'est marrant
car elle vraiment en lice tard les
petites filles viennent l'arrêter dans
la rue en disant qu est ce que tu es
belle plus tard je voudrais être comme
toi
ou susciter des vocations
je sais pas si c'est la vocation de se
trouver d'être libre je peux bien
susciter cette heure
là vous êtes ici ce soir pour vous
annoncer la sortie de votre calendrier
annuel
c'est un petit peu comme le calendrier
des postes mais il n'y a pas les chatons
taille à la maman
c'est mon 12e calendrier aujourd'hui
j'ai le produit totalement et j'en
produis d'autres aussi comme les pilotes
de la télé ou les hommes chez hugo n see
donc j'aime bien utiliser mon savoir
faire pour le faire pour d'autres
personnes aussi voilà on regarde making
of du calendrier
[Musique]
voilà car à morgane le calendrier de
clara morgane alors la musique du clip
ses vieilles dynaco alias jeremy olivier
votre mari vous l'avait épousé
religieusement
dans l'église notre dame de la serra à
calvi la trame de la série voilà tout à
fait finalement vous avez trois hommes
dans votre vie oui peu d' aventure mais
des grandes histoires et les belles
histoires le belge histoire flammes
[Musique]
voilà c'est l affaire de recel de fraude
pour les inconnus après la pub pour
discuter de l'actualité de la terre mais
canal vox la manga qui a tout fait ici
[Musique]
ramon soir les terriens rebond soit en
était rien
nous sommes toujours sur terre en
compagnie d'anne hidalgo
le clara morgane
ennemi inconnu
alors les inconnus re bonsoir
parallèlement à vos films j'ai vu
énormément de succès avec vos clips et
vos partie d'émission télé et
aujourd'hui vos parodie passerait pour
de vraies émissions en fait
il ya eu de vaud parvenir elles passent
moins souvent la télé que stéphanie de
monaco où l'hôpital mais qui est
extrêmement pertinente c'est celle de
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble bonjour
fabien s'allume je t'appelle le fun même
si tu permets pas
bon tu connais le principe de l'émission
je regarde jamais la télé
la télé pour moi compenser complètement
armoires qui sont datées des
100 soit c'est dire je te présente une
comédie c'est nous enrico macias
fonctionnons fait pas bien la faune
sauvage est inscrit dans notre de feu
sur la
maintiens mes cigarettes alors tu vas le
temps que tu veux la lui mais pas tout
de suite à tout à l'heure françois vite
attiré donc tu connais donc le principe
de l'émission
françoise françoise [__] il pense que
tu peux allumettes cigarettes un peu
plus loin s'il te plaît on y va on y va
on était sur la lune ouais tu croises
une martienne c'est complètement injuste
elle salue aussi recommencé à boire
comme chez moi qui ai décidé d'accord
bref
la martienne te propose soit une
gauloise soit une lucky strike soit
pétards extraterrestre qu'est ce qu'est
ce que tu choisis
ces pétards
perdu il n'y a pas d'herbe sur la lune
tout était dit françois
ce qu'on peut y
avoir d'accord qui peut juste de la
chance parce que j'en ai juste sur moi
oui voilà tranquille et c'est comme
jeter les seniors mais c'est plus près
et tu m'enlèves parce que j'ai un fjord
que j'ai pas fini
[Applaudissements]
terim subaru
non vous serez pas étonné qu'on fasse
une interview comme à l'époque à faire
une interview lunettes noires ou là
[Musique]
didier ce que tu préfères tu en perds ou
tu as ma fille tu vois comment sport
mon père n'est plus de ce monde de dire
ma mère parce que mon père m'en voudra
pas bien bonnes réponses
bernard mon père n'est plus de ce monde
mais j'ai dit à mon père pour faire
plaisir à ma mère
parce que c'est comme si tu me faisais
de choisir entre vannes et vanille et
chocolat ouais ça a donné un joli kinder
bueno
est ce que vous préférez iker jusqu'à
limoux c'est non mais c'est comme si tu
me disais de choisir entre federer et
nadal ces deux grands champions quoi
alors vous devez partir avec quelqu'un
trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial pour
[__] vous avez le choix entre claire
chazal christine bravo crêpa perry
damidot
armés ont fait exprès de choisir trois
plombes ouais bernard
cazals non non trois ans non
c'est là comment s'appelle bravo
avoir de quoi boire sinon
puisqu'on sait très vite au jeu pour
être inquiet plus ouais que jovialement
alors bah oui je prends valérie valérie
damidot batteur décorer la navette
avec des magnets violer tu vas être
content mais c'est ça alors si vous
aviez le choix est ce que vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide ou un mec très beau
personnellement j'ai fait les deux
[Applaudissements]
c'était il ya longtemps qu'il était bien
content id au débit
moi je dirais que ça m'est également
d'une pipe
pascal d'accord oui je fais d'abord avec
une bande s est pas terrible quand même
oui c'est vraiment faim c'est quand même
dur de draguer de l'aide fassent qu'à se
demande toujours pourquoi
question de philosophie maintenant y at
il une vie avant la mort
donc c'est une bonne question moi j'aime
bien la petite mort qui donne goût à la
vie a
alors plus facile maintenant quel est
notre punition préféré préféré pincer
mordu ou piquer moi je m'appelle bourbon
s'est piqué donc
alors là c'est beaucoup plus grave un
ami débarque chez vous à l'improviste ce
qui me gêne le plus c'est qu'ils
trouvent sur votre table de nuit mancka
me faut un godemichet à
aa
vraiment ce qui me j'aimerais vraiment
way dans cette manigance avec du sperme
de ton est
alors bien
non
dits les pilleurs michek une croix
gammée et voilà c'est exactement en
forme de croix gammée pour une partie
carrée
vous préféreriez vous réincarner en quoi
un berger allemand en setter irlandais
ou en épagneul breton j'ai une petite
chaîne c'est un cocker wec au coeur
c'est pas mal ses nerfs
bien qu'aucun poker français toi moi
j'ai un bichon j'adore ah c'est vrai un
bichon j'adore
pascal bats pas tu veux te ringard mais
mon petit bouquin détroit comme je suis
métisse en or dalmatiens
[Applaudissements]
attention est-ce que vous préféreriez
être aveugle et sourd ou amputé des bras
et des jambes oh [__] sourd comme ça
j'aurais pas entendu l'agression
attention questions fondamentales
si vous aviez un perroquet est-ce que
vous lui apprendre y y et à dire la
ferme et le gaz la france et à la capote
ou coco arrête là coco à
cécilia dieudonné qui veut chez moi ça
se rate à fermer le gaz
[Applaudissements]
et
oh
un idéal de roms ont soit
vous êtes candidat de la mairie de paris
alors la campagne se passe très très
bien je dois dire dans les sondages
devant votre votre adversaire assez
largement ça va j'aime bien ce moment où
on va convaincre qu'on va discuter on
apprend beaucoup de choses aussi c'est
un très joli moment et il se passe
plutôt bien oui il faut qu'il se termine
bien comment se termine bien alors
devant un comité de soutien incroyable
ça va du mathématicien cédric villani à
enrico macias pas lui je suis déjà
sarkozy un nom et enrico est quelqu'un
que je connais depuis longtemps et qui
m'avait dit si tu est candidate à la
mairie de paris je serai avec toi est
vraiment de façon très fidèle il a été
alors de votre comité de soutien il ya
aussi gérald dahan vous pensez que la
présence de gérald dahan peut faire
basculer le scrutin en votre faveur
j'aime bien gérald un an mais surtout
c'est un comité très large parce qu'il
ya des personnes très connues et puis il
ya plein de gens il ya des commerçants
des artisans des boulangers des bouchers
qui font partie aussi de mon comité de
soutien parce que c'est à l'image de pas
vous avez également le soutien d'alain
delon oui alors alain delon m allons-y
votre charme votre physique votre voix
votre façon de bouger il vous trouve
sensible attirante il a dit que vous
chantez l'espagne ça vous pas un peu les
jetons ça le soutien soutien d'alain
delon voilà c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
c'est vraiment un grand article alain
delon dernière fois qu'il a parlé
c'était pas pour dire du bien marine le
pen y voilà il ya des positions et leila
personnel oui il a un certain âge
maintenant non en tant qu'acquis pas ça
c'est vraiment quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup j'avais vraiment un comité de
soutien très très éclectique et dans ce
comité de soutien il ya aussi
les élections municipales c'est les 23
et 30 mars 2014 je vis à paris je vote
pour paris
voilà alors la mer là c'est énorme
elle a déclaré récemment qu'elle
appréciait beaucoup votre action en
faveur des deux roues motorisés puisque
et scooters motos non mais c'est ben oui
pourquoi pas
vous la connaissez bien non pas bien
mais c'est une actrice engagée depuis
longtemps engagée depuis longtemps c'est
vrai que ça fait deux ans qu'elle est
engagée
j'ai plus copine avec valérie
trierweiler ou non je suis très copine
avec valérie trierweiler moi c'est
vraiment une amie depuis très très
longtemps oui bon ben voilà alors on va
passer
non mais c'est la vie privée mais voilà
qu'on sait c'est la 5 conseillers payés
par les contribuables à l'elysée mais
c'est la vie privée si tu le vois là
quand elle va se reposer c'est à la
lanterne qui appartient à l'état mais
c'est la vie privée
[Applaudissements]
on va passer à votre programme
alors construction d'une deuxième tour
eiffel dans les quartiers populaires
pour que les pauvres en profite non même
très belle tour et celle déjà rendre
l'avenue foch piétonne ça c'est vrai
c'est pas bon non il ya des trucs vrai
vieux trucs pas vrai ils veulent pas
français alors d'abord faire rentrer le
bois de boulogne dans paris par la
sq étaient prévus au départ prévu au
départ par haussmann et elles sont qui
ont été ceux qui ont dessiné et paris et
le bois de boulogne et je trouve que
c'est une très belle idée de on peut
créer 60 hectares nouveau des espaces
verts dans paris autres points du
programme denis talbot baptisé dsk une
allée du bois de boulogne géant vivement
alors je ne sais pas le téléphérique
entre la gare de lyon la gare du nord
gare
d'austerlitz et gare de lyon en fait là
il ya une possibilité effectivement
voilà il ya des villes qui ont
expérimenté ça il faut qu'on regarde son
expérience mais c'est une bonne solution
pour se déplacer voilà donc un programme
on le voit ces riches
et puis à votre adversaire
nathalie kosciusko morizet
ah
bon je dirai pas si c'était ressemblant
à laure elle vous appelle l'héritière ça
lui va bien ça lui va très bien alors
que vous vos parents était votre père
ouvrier votre mère couturière je suis
pas né avec une cuillère d'argent et
comment ça s'appelle c'est en
psychanalyse que la projection paranoïa
et berlin elle vous reproche d'avoir été
inspectrice du travail vous aussi vous
auriez aimé ne pas avoir eu à travailler
mais moi j'étais très heureuse d'être
bien sûr c'est un super métier c'est un
bel apprentissage donc je revendique en
plus un métier que j'avais choisi méfiez
vous donne quand même un coma paraît
qu'elle s'est mise spiritisme pour
récupérer les électeurs fantômes de
tibérine non mais vous savez il ya même
des élus je citerai pas leur nom ici à
paris qui ont une magnétiseuse un élu de
droite un pari qu'il ya une magnétiseuse
qui le suit partout et qui vient à
toutes mes réunions qui
est maintenant on peut pleurer dit
si tu ne veux pas te retrouverai cet
intérêt de fermer ta gueule on ne peut
rêver
on peut le regarder
surtout on est d'accord avec toi mais
c'est pas nous ont fait la loi on peut
regarder et voilà on passe maintenant
l'actualité de la terre avec l'édito de
blacko et c'est le philosophe éditeur
françois l'yvonnet que nous retrouverons
sur ce plateau après le magnéto ce soir
nous demanderons c'est vrai qu'on veut
plus rien dire
c'est la tarte à la crème de tous les
débats sur la liberté d'expression
régulièrement l'actualité nous invite à
nous reposer la même question peut-on
rire de tout par exemple ces jours ci
sur france 2 olivier de benoist a tenté
de nous faire rire en comparant hollande
et mohamed merah prendra un scooter pour
aller tirer j'ai rien inventé mohamed
merah le faisait déjà ça vous étouffez
ruquier mais le lendemain sur france
inter patrick cohen s'indignait ils ont
fait la blague sur un tueur d'enfants
oui ils l'ont fait c'était mardi soir
juste avant le jt de france2 service
public résultat olivier de benoist cet
élève s'excuser là pas de vente à
s'excuser patrick timsit faisait rire
des salles entières avec une blague sur
les trisomiques mais pour éviter le
procès il a fini par s'excuser peut-être
qui sait certainement mal exprimé pour
le dire aussi et et puis bon ben il va
fait ses plus plates excuses pour
charlie hebdo en revanche pas question
de s'excuser après avoir publié les
caricatures de mahomet sarkozy qui était
ministre de l'intérieur à l'époque les a
soutenus en affirmant que l'excès de
caricature vaut mieux que l'absence de
caricature mais une fois à l'elysée ça
ne l'a pas empêché de porter plainte
contre une société qui bordaient des
poupées vaudous à son effigie et dans
laquelle on pouvait planter des
aiguilles pour s'amuser pour ceux qui
comme dieudonné refuse de s'excuser la
censure est sans pitié pourtant quand
dieudonné tenait des propos antisémites
dans ses sketches avec elie semoun tout
le monde était mort de rire
et ce combat pointe c'est qu'en pensant
que les proches il aurait pu finir le
boulot j'arrive à gérer pc qu'est-ce que
kddi vajira pc qui se tient mais
l'époque a changé dans les années 80 le
sketch de des proches sur les juifs
faisait rire on est le peuple élu et
pourquoi j'y réponds était au vélodrome
d'hiver
et qu'est ce que c'est que ces wagons
sans banquette et giraudoux si je veux
sauf que 20 ans plus tard quand
dailymotion à d'utiliser ce sketch sur
internet il a fallu fermer la page des
commentaires car elles des bords des
insultes antisémites
résultat la licra reconnaît
qu'aujourd'hui elle demanderait sans
doute l'interdiction d'un tel sketch sa
ressortir est aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
le seuil de tolérance n'est plus le même
qu'à cette époque là ça veut dire que si
ce skate ressort toujours vous iriez en
justice la question se poserait alors
est-ce qu'on peut encore rire de tout
ben a demandé aux inconnus dans les
années 90 ce qu'ils avaient fait un
sketch oui caricaturer 18 possibles aux
lettres pas dû arrêter voleurs nikkei
225 mois le sony c'est tout à fait 300
mille francs de différence alors
je n'ai sans doute pas lorsqu'elle est
le plus drôle pourtant il cartonne sur
internet avec plus de 4 millions de vues
en revanche sur la compil de l'intégrale
de leurs sketches ils ont conservé des
chiffres et des lettres version
polonaise
version belgique on commence tout fait
que monsieur membres
mais pas version israélienne
d'où l'éternelle question peut-on
vraiment rire de tout voilà c'est très
vite de l'aco
il en l'image de julien grave pas
françois il venait bonsoir vous êtes
philosophe vous êtes éditeur et ça et
vous allez publier en 2012 un essai qui
a fait beaucoup de bruit au mot comics
us ou l'intégrisme de la rigolade
chez fayard que je vous conseille
bienvenue parmi nous merci
alors les inconnus
pourquoi avoir supprimé
de vaud best-of votre sketch donc des
chiffres et des lettres en israël je
savais qu'il n'était pas mais je n'en ai
maintenant qu'ils sont pas là comme on
voit écrit l'intégrale on s'étonne que
ce soit pas l'intégrale mais il n'ya pas
que celui-là il y en a près de 25 4
d'accord
c'est pas très propre fait d'accord
quand olivier de benoist fait savane
vous trouvez qu'il a raison de s'excuser
il faut qu'ils assument enfin abordé tu
fais un quelque chose de consciemment si
après tout le retire ses co et us
interruptus je sais pas si c'est ça
c'est bizarre ouais non il faut passer
l'excusé sais que ça va s'excuser et
hinchey pareil quoi vous trouvez qu'il a
eu tort de s'excuser
pour jamais s'excuser voilà ce que dit
clara morgane serre que nous c'est un
peu différent parce que l'humour à 3 ça
nous permet vraiment de jeu des
personnages veut dire des horreurs sont
des personnages le problème c'est que
comme c'est des one man show man on sait
pas si c'est un personnage ou pas
coluche il avait beau mettre un nez
rouge les gens se demandaient ce qui est
raciste et ce qui est pas raciste
d'ailleurs dieudonné est lié à l'époque
dieudonné jouer vraiment un personnage
qui est envoyé chier au haut débit donc
c'est pas pareil que quand on est face
seul on sait pas si c'est dû mourir et
jules home and s'excuser peut-être pas
mais en tous les cas
on a changé d'époque clairement il ya
des choses qui heurte ya un air du temps
qui est très complet il faut on peut
plus arrêter des gens je trouve qu'il ya
quand même une sensibilité à fleur de
peau la montée des extrémismes sur libé
g sur tout un tas de sujets de société
on voit bien qu'on est quand même dans
une société dont les traits crispés
qu'on soit dans une époque spécialement
crispés ou où les tensions sont
forcément exacerbée je pense que
simplement avec les réseaux sociaux et
la communication et la presse
effectivement les choses sur deux savent
plus et les gens qui s'expriment
davantage et de tous bords qui qu'il
soit il faut faire un effort collectif
non pas pour être sérieux mais pour se
remettre en tête des éléments de mémoire
quand dieudonné parle et fait du
négationnisme il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ne sont pas ne se sont pas replonger qui
n'ont pas été voir du côté par exemple
de l'histoire de la shoah et qui ne
comprennent pas qu'en même temps on est
en train de piétiner la mémoire de
millions de personnes qui se sont fait
exterminer d'accord alors françois ils
venaient toutes ses phrases de comics
qui prennent une importance incroyable
vous en pensez quoi je crois d'abord que
parmi les comics et des comics différent
quand on parle du dieu de dieudonné pour
moi dieudonné n'est plus un comique
c'est devenu un politique ouais donc il
faut le juger en tant que politique et
les hommes politiques devraient avoir
l'honnêteté de le juger en tant que
politique et de ne pas faire le procès
de l'humour donc yaya dieudonné guillon
aussi à ce moment là non parce que
guillon incarne pour moi quelque chose
que je n'aime pas à savoir une forme
d'humour des puissants d'humour
d'efforts contre l'humour des faibles
c'est quelqu'un qui est installée auprès
du pouvoir parfois trop près du pouvoir
et qui donne des leçons un humour qui
donne des leçons et pour - umicore donc
vous l'été vous mettez dans le même sac
alévêque ou et et portent par exemple
sur coluche voulu rien maintenant
coluche c'est un c'est un moment à mon
avis pivot suis pas un historien de
l'humour et un pivotement vers un rat
iman de l'humour à des causes sont des
causes disons le assez bien pensante
pourquoi vous dites qu'ils sont proches
du pouvoir et parce que cela se constate
d'abord ils sont prêts qu'est ce que
c'est que le pouvoir le pouvoir c'est
pas des ministres où madame le maire le
pouvoir c'est l'argent ces gens sont
trois très proche de l'argent ils sont
là où se trouve l'argent et vous
remarquerez que quand ils sont
impertinent ils le sont il est à la
rigueur à l'égard des politiques mais
jamais à l'égard de ceux qui les payent
celles ci sont très respectueux ce sont
des petits chiens respectueux riom il
accueille en attaque et france inter
inquiets qu'ils paient c'est vrai mais
il avait il avait tout de même une
prébende arrière qui était canal oui je
peux vous dire c'est qu'il ya peut-être
dans cette salle des gens qui ont perdu
leur emploi ils n'avaient pas ce type de
soutien sur bien sûr soyons honnêtes
vous savez ça vous c'est insupportable
je trouve ça insupportable moi j'aime
beaucoup les humoristes qui d'abord ont
un talent le premier des talents c'est
l'auto dérision ça évite déjà deux de se
poser comme comme une sorte d'
ayatollahs qui donne des leçons il ya un
personnage qui pour moi jouent un rôle
désastreux dans cette affaire c'est jean
michel ribes qui en voilà qui est très
près du pouvoir et non pas du tout
cissé mais non vous mélanger non
c'est un comique de course est en effet
cela et d'autre part c'est quelqu'un qui
s'est permis de dire qu'il y avait un
humour de résistance et un humour de
collaboration lumeau de résistance à
savoir le sien c'est-à-dire du bon côté
avec évidemment le bien le mot de
collaboration c'est à dire les autres
déjà le vocabulaire est un vocabulaire
qui est extrêmement dangereux cette
diabolisation bain d'un rire qui n'est
pas le bon rire et cela vous pouvez pas
dire le contraire ça ce sas observe
sans doute ce qui concerne par exemple
jean michel ribes c'est un créateur
c'est un directeur d'un grand théâtre il
un jour non non moi y'a t'il pas près
les pouvoirs n'a pas commenté m je vous
mets pour vous érigé en censeur et c'est
qu'ils
sont du mauvais pied ce que je constate
c'est qu'on ait fait c'est quelqu'un qui
est proche de votre parti par conséquent
vous le défendez c'est très bien c'est
top c'est une qualité des artistes que
j'apprécie mais vous pouvez apprécier
l'artiste le fait qu'il soit directeur
d'un théâtre qui l'accueille de ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'est pas près du pouvoir
et que sa proximité du pouvoir change la
donne non mais ce que vous dites sur le
sur la politique je pense que c'est très
très vrai même si on apprécie beaucoup
anne hidalgo je pense que ce n'est pas
notre rôle de faire partie on met
toujours garder notre liberté lundi mort
d'anna dépendance c'est forcément un
être humain qui a dépensé qui a des
convictions donc dans votre course ça
transparaît forcément oui mais à la
maison est ce que les artistes ou les
intellectuels doivent rester
complètement en dehors de l'engagement
si on a envie de s'engager on s'engage
et chacun est libre de ses engagements
et on est dans une politique solide
lincoln médiatisé donc voilà on avait
parlé tout à l'heure du soutien d'alain
delon oui et on vous a opposé qu elle a
de longs étaient en même temps a mis i'm
in marine le pen vous n'avez pas l'air
d'être gênés par ce genre de situation
pour vous ça vous semble parfaitement
naturel galindo l'on puisse être à la
fois votre soutien et à la mine marine
le pen je fais partie sans doute de de
nombreuses personnes qui ne font pas
partie de cette petite élite que vous
êtes qui shoote surpris généré je trouve
ça je trouve ça aberrant vous fixez vos
règles du jeu des règles du jeu que vous
pensez être celle qui ferait qui serait
dans les biens et
l'environnement
la cohérence alors est-ce que les
humoristes aujourd'hui ne se prennent
pas pour des intellectuels finalement
ils se prennent parfois pour les
intellectuels parce que souvent les
intellectuels ont déserté la place qui
était la leur c'est surtout que beaucoup
d'humoristes ne sont plus simplement
humoriste qui sont à la fois journaliste
chroniqueur dans la scéne ans des dogmes
et ça ça me ça me dérange alors est ce
qu'aujourd'hui fait plus attention est
ce que vous pourriez écrire qu'à
l'époque non alors là dessus il ya une
relation entre les interviews à l'époque
il ya 20 ans disait que des inconnus
étaient plutôt gentil jamais méchant et
aujourd'hui on nous dit mais il ya vingt
ans vous faisait des sketches que vous
ne pourriez plus faire aujourd'hui vous
voyez c'est toujours sur un petit peu de
relativité est ce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
peut freiner les humoristes est-ce que
c'est l'âge d'issia risation ou est-ce
que c'est l'autocensure
le développent une c est ce qu on
appelle l' autocensure c'est ce que
l'éducation aussi c'est d'avoir le
respect de l'autre gers et la civilité
il est clair que parfois il ya des
défauts de civilité et quand on parle
par exemple d'un nouvel antisémitisme
qui se développe c'est évident pas le
contester c'est super ça pose un
problème un autre problème c'est pas
simplement de dire les temps sont
différents c'est aussi se demander si la
manière que nous avons eu tous pour
essayer de combattre un certain nombre
de fléaux si ça a été efficace par
conséquent avant de mobiliser la morale
appliquons le droit
mais c'est vrai c'est le problème du
moralisme qui le maurice ne jette ne
règle rien ce que nietzsche appelait la
morale il oui d'injecter de la moraline
c'est vrai que ça on injecte la
perfusion de la moraline c'est quelque
chose que qui est assez bien partagé
bien françois merci d'avoir été avec
nous voilà c'était la clé 2 le slt en
sorte qu'on apprenne à tulle avec le
jazz et pop et notre carrière du samedi
20 heures ce soir avec 6 mastic
le dr molly des jeux olympiques dont les
larges sur le riz avait ému toute la
france il va par combat a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'homme en sont à l'intérieur bonsoir
câlins nous sommes toujours sur terre en
compagnie d'anne hidalgo
la morgan et des inconnus
et nous accueillons notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures ce soir alexis vastine
bonsoir
alors alexis vastine
par deux fois le jeux olympiques de
pékin en 2008 et à ceux de londres en
2012 vous êtes clairement fait voler
votre victoire par les arbitres suite à
cette deuxième injustice nous avait
sombré dans la dépression et puis tel
rocky vous êtes relevé vous avez remis
les gants vous avez recommencé
l'entraînement
et vous comptez bien devenir enfin
champions olympiques à rio en 2016 faut
dire que c'est votre dernière chance
vous nous raconter votre histoire à 20h
dans un instant gaspard proust mais
d'abord le zapping
c'était le zapping j'accueille
maintenant gaspard proust pour elle est
pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce qu'on peut rire de tout oui
mais pas avec n'importe qui non pas du
coup ce qui explique sans doute pourquoi
c'est très dur de rire de tout avec les
gens de gauche
vous n'êtes pas de gauche ah non non
vous êtes beaucoup trop excitant pour ça
non ça c'est vraiment assez rare alors
bien sûr est ce qu'on pourrait dire
aujourd'hui ce que disait autrefois les
anciens les inconnus coluche desproges
raymond barre félix potin est ce qu'on
peut se permettre ça non évidemment
évidemment mais pourquoi on ne peut pas
bafouer trop aujourd'hui au siècle des
lumières comics nous autres les énarques
de la galéjade nous les normaliens du
jeu de mot du ricanement académique nous
les futurs inconnus via autrefois les
sketchs été décortiqués par bouvard
martin aujourd'hui tu as vu on ferait
finkielkraut bhl
caron qui est leur maître à penser à
tous bien sûr alors pourquoi aujourd'hui
est pas fière elle même parce qu'il faut
croire que les humoristes étaient
incapables d'avoir une pensée autrefois
il était beaucoup plus con
alors sinon quoi d'autre de l'actu lors
épilogue des feux de l'amour donc
elysées c'est fini et je suis un peu
déçu et choqué je suis choquée vous
dirai and franchement vu que c'est lui
qui s'est fait prendre la main dans le
sac normalement quand c'est l'homme qui
fit la femme c'est lui qui quitte le
domicile conjugal mais qu'est ce qu'il
faut à l'elysée
alors quand elle a pris l'adultère
trierweiler a déclaré j'ai l'impression
tombé du haut d'un gratte-ciel main mais
si elle a cru tomber d'un immeuble on
tient au moins une certitude elle va
rebondir
et après la lanterne à est parti se
reposer en inde alors lui est parti en
turquie bon alors n'attendez pas de moi
que je fasses une blague sur les toits
les turcs c'est vraiment pas du niveau
non vraiment même si c'est quand même
grâce à ce système qu on comprend
pourquoi la turquie a toujours été très
bien placé dans les compétitions
internationales
en haltérophilie
[Rires]
ouais elle et elle est longue à arriver
mais une fois qu'on a l'image on décolle
plus
alors lui son côté évidemment on se sent
plus sûr de lui il ya quelque chose que
ben moi déjà je m'identifie beaucoup
plus quand la manière qu'il a eue de
renvoyer sa meuf on aurait dit moi face
à un plan cul
j'ai décidé en total accord avec moi
même qu il est une heure du matin j'ai
déjà joué et que je dors mieux quand je
dors tout seul
alors on lui reproche d'avoir utilisé le
jeu le jeu un peu de patience avec
l'assurance qu'il est en train de
prendre ce qu' il va surprendre la
prochaine intervention évade il va
parler du à troisième personne ce sera
lu président enfin il le sait et
choisira qui va partager son pieu stop
ça suffit les minutes tu dégages oui lui
président il dira oui je te veux je ne
te veut plus oui la comédienne pousse
toi bien la journaliste est par ici la
danseuse du crazy chauds les marrons
poussez-vous je voulais faire
lui président il ne versera pas la
courbe du chômage
comme j'ai prévu non désolé j'ai échoué
je t'emmerde c'est comme ça je suis ce
que je veux
le président et directeur de halo
bécassine c'est bien des lois contre le
sexisme et moi je suis un ado je suis
libre casse calibur
carli président enfin il le sait
maintenant il le dit
je dis non car je suis à l'adolescence
elle de l'essence ont dit non alors non
lus président rires je rappelle les
innus des esclaves rami dit il n'ira pas
au séminaire sur la parité et non le
président il fera pas du socialisme
freddy thatcher juste vous faire caca
sur la moutte à mélenchon voilà
[Applaudissements]
jour de colère les manifs sujet un peu
de temps j'ai vu ça c'est chaud c'est
moi je sais pas si je vais sur ce après
je reste quelqu'un de prozac est simple
dans cette manif on a vu des slogans
antisémites et homophobes et c'est pas
bien un autre côté il faut reconnaître
que dans les manifs de gauche il ya
souvent des slogans anti fasciste oui
il y a tort qui a raison je suis pas
assez intelligent pour trancher
je sais pas anniversaires clara morgane
est né à 25 janvier comme jean-marc
ayrault comme quoi l'astrologie c'est
vraiment de la merde
[Applaudissements]
marseille règlement de comptes entre
trafiquants
un homme a été abattu à la kalachnikov
devant son fils
va faire rire avec ça
alors le fils a été épargnée bon c'est
normal le gamin il a vu l'agresseur et
la dir est pas moi c'est une
bonne nouvelle alors il paraît que
schumacher se réveille doucement façon
faut pas trop le brusque et enfin ça
c'est normal tu imagines tu dis un
champion international domicilié à
monaco bonjour tu est soigné à grenoble
non alors
en plus si un allemand quoi le vercors
n'est pas loin
c'est pas que des bons souvenirs pour
ces gens là alors elle est pas belle la
vie
sylla demain à 15 heures sur canal
et sur canalplus.fr on passe maintenant
à notre terriens du samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
alexis vastine re bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
mu est né le 17 novembre
1986 à pont-audemer dans leur père
employé municipal maire travaille dans
une usine de cartes à puce et il ya avec
vous quatre autres enfants une famille
passionnée de sport à commencer par vos
parents votre mère a pratiqué le
handball à haut niveau et votre père la
boxe professionnelle et vos frères
bossard vote enfin toute la famille et
dont le sport vous enfilez vos premiers
gants de boxe à l'âge de 6 ans c'est ça
alors l'âge normal ces huit ans ou huit
ans l'élégant sont plus gros que votre
tête et quand vous rentrez chez vous en
pleurant vous vous dites quand même que
vous avez envie de gagner quoi parce que
j'avais tellement envie de réussir déjà
mais là je perdais logiquement
1 13 ans vous quittez votre famille pour
le centre sport études de vendôme dans
le loir-et-cher à 14 ans vous êtes déjà
champion de france minimes et à 17 ans
vous êtes champion de france juniors à
19 ans vous êtes médaille d'or aux jeux
de la francophonie
c'est ça alors là vous commencez à rêver
aux jeux olympiques de pékin 2008
et vous vous préparez donc pour les jeux
olympiques c'est effroyable à la
préparation un oui bah de torture ouais
ouais vraiment certaines fois vous
évanouissiez pendant les séances
d'entraînement quoi basse avec les
régimes n'allait pas que je faisais un
mètre 84 que je fais aujourd'hui
actuellement et mais je faisais 64 kg
donc à la proche des compétitions tirs
sur l'eau est ce qu'il faut pas faire
sur les séances de
pm a donc deux courses à fractionner
d'efforts on perd la tête
il vous arrive de vous faire vomir pour
perdre 100 g avant la pesée afin que me
faisait vomir en 64 kg ouais quand
arrivent les jeux olympiques de pékin en
2008 vous avez 21 ans vous enchaînez les
combats avec brio jusqu'à la demi finale
votre adversaire s'appelle felix diaz
c'est 1 2 min qu'un d'un mètre 65 très
brouillon et vous êtes évidemment
meilleur que lui lorsqu'il faut savoir
c'est que aux jeux olympiques on ne
cherche pas le chaos on cherche la
touche à fin du combat vous êtes à dix
touchent chacun est là vingt secondes
avant la fin du combat larbitre vous
inflige une pénalité complètement
injustifiée ben ouais parce que ce que
vous étiez meilleur j'étais meilleur et
puis je me suis donné corps et âme pour
quoi rêver là alors on va voir cette
séquence qui a ému tout le monde
[Musique]
quatre reprises une parodie non c'est
une honte
c'est un scandale il a été volé avec
sébastien il a été volée au louvre en
laisse
pique
on a envie de crier notre révolte parce
que c'est vrai
injuste n'est pas méritée pour non à
l'exil
pas loin
quelle injustice ouais alors à ce
moment-là quand brahim asloum qui a
gagné à sydney s'approche de vous vous
lui dites des années de travail pour une
médaille de bronze médaille de merde
c'est comme si un enfant dit travaille
bien à l'école toute l'année et aura un
cadeau à noël le petit à 20 sur 20
toulon et la fin de la vente se tient
une orange
alors à ce moment là vous pensez arrêté
la boxe et puis de retour en france vous
relativiser un peu évidemment vous êtes
dégoûtés mais vous avez quand même une
médaille et puis les gens dans la rue
ouais alexis bon c'est sympa vous
trouver des sponsors enfin bon vous
avalez un peu la couleuvre vous avez que
21 ans et ce moment là vous vous dites
je vais remonter la pente iniesta fait
logique ça s'est fait très vite parce
que comme je suis militaire à côté j'ai
remonté à cheval directement parce que
j'ai fait les championnats du monde
militaires et vous gagnez jeu
là vous commencez à vous entraîner pour
les jeux olympiques de londres
ah ça recommence à 8 heures par jour à
suez à saigner vous faites des combats
aux quatre coins du monde pour vous
préparer à tous les types d'adversaires
possible et vous les montrer au monde
entier que vous allez mieux qu'une
médaille de bronze bien sûr j'ai pas
être pour moi j'ai pas été jugé c'est ça
qui est frustrant j'ai pas été jugée à
ma juste valeur alors aux jeux
olympiques de londres en 2012
vous avez 25 ans vous êtes au mieux de
votre forme vous passer les premiers
tours sans problème jusqu'au quart de
finale et là à la fin du combat vous
avez six touches de plus que votre
adversaire qui est dépité lui c'est
qu'il a perdu ou vous saute il ya un peu
de joie ce qui est tout à fait normal et
là contre toute attente larbitre soulève
le bras de votre adversaire le
proclamant vainqueur en fait vous aviez
18 touche chacun mais il lui donne
davantage j'entends dans la salle où
comme ça
et je voyais à mon frère qui est en face
dans votre tribune il y avait les
escaliers je vois et une cliente
inquiète enfin je lis sur ses gestes et
tout
et après
la suite je suis un bras s'est pas levée
on regarde
[Musique]
au non non c'est pas possible
oh non c'est pas vrai 18 et
préférentielles 18 ans j'avais de la
misère
insupportable je voulais ramener la
médaille pour la france et pour tous
ceux qui me
voilà ma mère en train de travailler
jusqu'à 6 ans le matin je l'embrassais
[Applaudissements]
à
attendez c'est truqué ses matchs ou quoi
ce que le maquis les ukrainiens on nous
explique toute la journée à la télé en
ce moment c'est un régime corrompu
puisqu'il ya la possibilité de
corruption
non mais là après ça vous dit c'est
insupportable et ce soit là rien ne peut
vous faire évader de votre cauchemar
ouais parce que j'ai tout donné pour ce
sport j'ai pas fait de grandes études et
je me suis intéressé à rien d'autre qu'à
ce sport je voulais être un champion et
voilà tout mais
bien le résultat me convient pas c'est
là vous perdez vos sponsors et puis des
potes aussi c'est à dire que y'a que vos
proches qui reste autour de vous la tous
nous disent avant qu'on réussisse ou
vous comme ça mais on se dit mais non
pas moi et tout mais en fait ouais c'est
comme ça après mes proches m'ont à ma
copine mais mes amis du sport sont
toujours ont toujours été là alors là ce
qui est incroyable c'est que la
fédération vous dit tu as donné une
mauvaise image de la boxe et on vous
retire votre licence on retire pas ma
licence mais on m'enlève de l'insset en
fait tu m'avais en retirer mais z et
vous retire quand même 800 euros par
mois quoi c'est pas rien non c'est pas
rien
j'avoue sombrer dans la dépression
l'alcool buvait beaucoup je buvais
beaucoup ouais vide j'ai pu voir rien à
ce moment-là vous laisser un peu aller
quoi moi je pensais des idées sont ré
vais penser à vous suicider à l'époque
il faut je me posais la question comment
web mais je comprends les gens en fait
j'arrive à comprendre les gens qui se
suicident oncle antoine a plus rien mais
je l'aurais pas fait ouais vous allez
voir un psy ouais ça marche bien ouais
ouais mais c'est vrai prem propre psy
c'est moi et la boxe pour l'instant
parce que je me rattache à ça encore en
tous les cas pour commencer à vous
entraîner voile après sept mois de oued
de dérapage enfin je puis vous vous
dites toute façon je sais faire que ça
alors
ouais enfin je pense bah oui je pense
que je peux prendre à faire d'autres
choses j'ai pris du recul aussi ex il ya
eu du beaucoup de mal dans cette
dépression mais aussi des bonnes choses
alors j'ai déjà grillé deux cartouches
donc pékin et londres il en reste une si
elle est ou 2016 ont d'abord fait les
perdre du poids
vié 15 kilos à perdre vata combien - 7
sept
ça va
alors vous dites si je gagne médaille
olympique
je fais 50 mille euros quand même c'est
charmant vous dites je vais avec mes
potes et mes proches passer un week-end
au bord de la mer ouais ouais pendant un
week-end un voilà je trouve ça parce que
les plaisirs les plus simples
sont les meilleurs mais j'avais vu aussi
ça on en a des pressions est-ce que vous
allez vous raser la barbe si vous gagnez
mais en fait la barbe c'est pas et c'est
la dépression et puis je me suis imposé
enfin je me suis donné un pari c'est
quand je boxe la race en tous les cas
pour un mec qui s'est pris des coups
depuis l'âge de 6 ans dans la gueule
vous êtes bien conserver vos dons c'est
les vôtres à part celle là j'ai perdu la
patinoire pas
alors votre rage de vaincre est intacte
déjà c'est pour ma santé fait que je
reprenne pour retrouver un équilibre et
puis surtout j'ai fait de la peine à mes
proches et quand j'ai commencé à leur
faire de la peine ça m'a
mis du plomb dans la tête
[Applaudissements]
le témoignage mais aussi beaucoup on
vous souhaite le meilleur et on sera là
on va vous de suivre un appui je sais
pas si on te l'a déjà dit mais si ça
marche pas tout cas je te souhaite pas
tu peux remplacer m pokora dans robin
des bois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà j'étais salut les terriens votre
retour du samedi soir avec un idéal tôt
merci candidate c'est ça l'amérique tard
et clara morgane
clara morgane iconique et en rendent les
inconnus et grand père leur tour ça sort
le 12 février ça va cartonner jetant
françois vives des philosophes éditeurs
alexis vastine merci encore de votre
démarrage annexe i
[Applaudissements]
je vous signale que bibi tanga de
gréement de fortune et ton concert à
l'alhambra le 8 février dans le cadre du
festival au fil des voix bravo libye
bravo les filles
merci à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire
cette émission je vous laisse avec
roland on est bon ici la semaine
prochaine mais d'ici là sur canalplus.fr
avec en bonus le top des vagues l'édito
de l'aco les meilleurs atteint d'une
forme à quai et gâche la rose saluer
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de la
latitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu